All right, I'm now sharing a Googler
shopping list with Frank, Jenny,
and Abe.
The sharing feature is pretty slick.
>> I'm glad you like it.
It certainly wasn't an easy
road to get to this point.
Let's take a look at what we've
accomplished in the wire frames.
At the start of version 0.4, we added
some basic sorting functionality to make
it easier to find shopping lists.
>> This helped users
organize their lists.
But what we really needed was sharing.
After some prophetic guidance,
we decided to go with a denormalized
data structure that would support
our need for
quick look ups of users' shopping lists.
This increased the amount
of data we were storing but
ultimately saved the users time.
>> Right, and after that data change,
you were able to make a sharing flow.
Where users added other
users to a friends list, and
then turn sharing on and off.
>> Furthermore, we simplified this
flow by adding auto complete search
functionality when
typing in user emails.
>> Great work.
>> Great.
And now I'm off to do
some guerilla marketing.